il calcio oggi ma mai più belle scuro
logica chi stava in aria magia
io volevo mettere a rischio le cose e
tutto ciò dovremo fare un gameplay per
la spesa salvo dei cookie noi no senza
cuffie papa allora dentro è un attimo
simone finanziato un attimo si ma non
fate così fino alla fine che il prossimo
rilascio non partirà mai questa è la gt
ragazzi mito questo nuovo episodio di
anfield
questa era la propulsione del bello a
tutti i ragazzi che hanno fatto andare
indietro simona dei ragazzi siamo su è
più iss con volevo farlo da solo poi
c'era suri poi c'era poi vabbè poi addio
perché so che toni che io mi devo pagare
così pezzetta mi devo sfogare in qualche
modo per ora vorrei vedere la
descrizione è vero o hackerato questa
mappa vediamo la città ma al menù da
papà ma ci preme è la legge 8 francesco
pazienza sword troppo cimone a questa e
una meno africa mi piace questo gioco
momento è bellissima hanno fatto dopo
croce lovino di minecraft è difficile ci
prendi lo vorrei mai gratis e di
diamanti ovviamente spiega
e che cosa succede marito manovra
questa è l'ultima volta che lo ritrovo e
poi basta sono solo a 140 papa si chiama
sia qualcuno che ha fatto più di te che
si chiama minecraft riduce ai 20 video
sul canale
voglio dire uccide il bambino non
dovresti dare questi consigli papa ma
questo è il gioco aspetta e manca
l'ultimo che vedete a destra dove doveva
fare mai di bambini con l'amico nocerina
non è bastato il cazzo che mi porto il
film papa.il fifa e manchino solo cadere
in piedi ben appoggiati sia fa
recuperare anche che vi esaltate a è
vero o no i fan ci credeva non ci
riuscirò a menarla un po di suspance
anche bordello troppo pare che lì ci
vedo nessuna caduta di la roba il
gioiello questi siete bravi questo
risulta napoli sono da napoli e non mi
scusi che questo momento la guardasse
con un gamer simon c'è il mouse quindi
rubare gioielli da questa sera iniziando
magari piccolo all'asilo alla si fa
persino la gente si muove fatto una
brutta fine
ho ancora le gambe si aspetta è
ufficiale di tab brevi tam tam tam tam
tam sa che cos'è il caffè alto e alto
esportare volte allora senti facciamo
un'altra gara questa non è capace c'è un
brutto anno ero un po più sera tornano
godo una roba per simone a me sembra è
premuto un tasto insultando zio tenebre
cercato di girarmi
il primo giro ho capito è semplicissimo
facciate come si fa così parete paese
sì ma porca [ __ ] devi tenere un
attimino possiamo fatto a 2 maicon salvo
sta bene sta bene da me va bene almeno
una volta
certo doveva cedere la skill di uno dei
giocatori tutti i giorni
ragazzi siamo perché io non li modo da
quando avevo 16 anni problema queste le
faccio per in the box che mi sembra che
vieni klaus vieni qua ti faccio vedere
così io lo faccio e tu lo replica dal
taglio aggrappare qua e fare così era
presa molto serio che ti deve aggrappare
la parola spaziatrice dunque perché poi
ti molli quando malati no adesso papa
d'amore ma la palla va da questa bambina
all'asilo è così ma cosa parliamo dei
bambini ha allestito potete allora
allunga le braccia non è banale giovane
già così spazio a pazzini 6 minuto
sempre molto simili adesso fai la
capriola linee collage cascina mano
finte che si tutto rispetto
vai lascia un attimo
[Applauso]
era proprio il livello di merda riusciti
a farlo tutti è una cagata casciana
album questo è carino di prendere
l'arpione mente vuole fare le cose per
ritirare nel culo maria malizia tutti
noi tutti è perché c'è solo questo ogni
tanto mangio per ora spetta ai aveva uno
pro vinto è stato dimesso under signor
lac questo va solo a culo quindi può
essere bravo no no perché cosa devi fare
di andare lì scaricare sul verde non più
il mio colore ho beccato la morte papa
sui punti interrogativi verso il blu in
situ lasciato a farci avanti
stasera c'è il mio mi devi prendere
capito un macello
la barca [ __ ] po più piano se non il
proprio passo qui faccio aste scendendo
dalla papa ecco che cosa
posso vedere un livello fatto da un fan
per te a vigere parigi e di aver giocato
quale sia sopravvissuto che da lei fa
vidi vici con la sla che liberò si è
affatto resterebbe volontario e quindi
sopra vive sotto morire e non va bene
perché sopra mormorii non la posso fare
attenzione a ciò che è accaduto è una
dei parchi voglio vedere cosa succede se
una sola traccia bella e difficile
oddio lo dico contro maledizione c'è uno
cioè non c'è chi sinceramente non farti
domande papa porgeva abbia parlato
perché papa parla in parlato ha parlato
di giuseppa parlava bene così poi per n
1 fatto bene dicendo ho fatto bene dai
la vincenzi e capace che ha sfidato
faceva un cazzo sei infamando la ganga
la gamba di ieri non si fanno a gara
faccio io polo con un nonno senza che
questi se aveva ragione dopo la vittoria
morale va vittore un green screen menti
dei pony di sfondo bellissima grazie vj
questo è bello ha confermato pro insegna
come un po l'italiano con ferocia che lo
ha scritto bene però in relazione al
livello e ho capito che non vedeva dal
cena per strada comincia qui ci vediamo
la conoscenza riga ragazzi dei divi
dominare la bandiera credessimo c'è
scritto questo è un mito dei giapponesi
esatto bangladesh dove esatto aspettare
di bangladesh come il bangladesh
imatinib anche la tematica sono quelli
che vendono le bagarre in a dove la fiat
e le sue pentole e picchiato italiani
per l'amministrazione il mio ma rimarrà
a san pietro
cates incontro ti stai tracimati si
vabbè ma ragazzi in c da questa dipende
da noi contro la capitale da sempre e da
questa sulle banche stanno facendo
giorno le usiamo frog splash vai al
contrario ai [ __ ] splash nick jump e
basta poco basta mezz'ora 8 agosto della
clementi nomi che già ragazzi di jump da
fare se non fai casino quale è la prima
è l'emblema del ddl non è
io dico così può accompagnare però a
pagare solo su quello dietro che avvenga
la divisa porti anche quello per tutto
ciò perché sta pedalando sistemare messo
a tacere che vivi nokia fate domande dei
ragazzi dire che questo video poi con
cui lo si può è stato veramente figo più
di tanto di a mente come un momento è un
bel like passate a tutti i canali che
trovate in descrizioni di questi bei
ragazzi anche solo dl che mettono in the
kitchen e via dicendo generatività
chiavari social media nei commenti
scrive se fa leggevo gli occhi mi sta
bene che ci sei bello con gli occhi ma
perché ed amava e da ieri ai occhiolino
quello che vino che ci ha fatti e noi ci
rivediamo ad un prossimo video e spegne
negli stati ragazzi è inizio